they leave this on hello and welcome to
the Carl and Chris podcast live from
Phoenix Arizona USA kira soltanovich how
are you I'm chewing you're chewing your
yum I am my guest Carl's in the it's
2:00 a.m. in the UK he could set an
alarm but he wouldn't be funny he'd be
tired come on he'd be tired to be on
skype but you were in town
Here I am you may be trying to do this
for a long time yes and I felt bad
because I was doing something and I was
blonde she postponed but you I think it
was for like filming and I was like I
was shooting was every why yeah yeah I
was shooting all oh yeah yeah it was a
show on Fox called punchline OCO and it
was like a kind like a game show but
again game show I have like a game show
theme but it wasn't like it was like a
@midnight type of game show so not real
game show just comics riffing and
telling jokes
I had him I've never thought that game
shows in my life till had a chat with
someone ever this is very la Welsh
answer this guy I know through someone
and I said I had a really literally am I
had a dumb idea for a podcast for a game
show you know that's a great idea let's
make that I was like really I mean my
and I'm like that's it's not gonna but I
mean I was like maybe me I love mountain
now Chris mine I've no one makes his
millions off a game [ __ ] I mean so you
know that game show what's the game show
Aaron Aaron I always go to Aaron he's
very siren is he's lonely howie mandel
with the briefcases dealer note thank
you oh yeah that said that was started
revived his career also revived in the
UK so this is a good little US UK what
was wrong of his career but is he the
guy's a judge on it was wrong now he's a
judge on a million other game shows but
or reality shows whatever they call but
nothing was wrong with his career but he
just had such a huge high in the 80s and
90s right into the 90s and you know he
was still around always doing stuff like
when I was on The Tonight Show he would
come on The Tonight Show and do like
really funny silly pranks and
hidden-camera throwings and whacky stuff
but it wasn't what it turned into after
Deal or No Deal so game shows are a pun
intended game changer but we
a lot from the UK the show I'm working
on right now is a UK show well I mean
I'm not saying your career needs
reviving but I'm saying there's the the
British deal or no deal revived the
career I think it was first before the
amount of a guy called Knoll Edmonds
whose career went bad because on his old
TV show someone died live on TV what he
had a show called Noel's house party and
on live TV I think a bungee jump they
did it and a guy it went wrong and a guy
died No Deal
it made a guy who'd been part of a show
that killed someone's career go back on
the radar how can you even bounce back
just not even funny
why massive pun intended that but how
not even career-wise but just like just
living just being a human just living on
the earth like how even though it's not
his fault
no it's you feel like an accomplice to a
murder yeah I mean I guess you could
break it to you the presenter you're not
in charge of checking the wires right
right it seems like restless the Owen
Hart passed away when yeah yeah I guess
you'd like you'd there's someone or
someone's at fault but there's if you go
to the root of it there's a guy who was
in charge checking as wise [ __ ] or the
wire maker right doesn't have made the
wires or go back to there I didn't check
the bun do you want minerals that the
mountain yeah mine was where does it end
Harper where does it end but I do one I
do wonder if oh here we go
Doug this is like a sitcom this is the
Kramer comes in Hey duck Stan I broke
into the studio hey man Becker come on
hey man yes I guess they have a new
co-host
hey we factorize wife is being a douche
she doesn't even are we stepping on your
podcast time we're so sorry we're so
sorry dad nice is Friday oh sorry oh
okay I'll see you tomorrow Matt okay
that was the best that was the best that
was the best u-turn of a guy who was so
sure he was correct and then I thought
it'd take me a lot of convinced he was
just like it's cuz the accent whatever
when I said something in British and I'm
Stanhope this went
yep Queen's English and doesn't matter
what you say that was like that was that
look like I would they didn't I don't
think they did that intentionally but
like yeah you're adorable they're
adorable ready gullible yes he did his
live podcast yesterday yeah they did
that is a bit that's a bit I know I'm
very I'm very gullible but you know like
some people say I just don't get why
people would like why would he do that
to me it's a door well the person that
died in those house party I feel like
Adam 2:17 that's not that happened in 92
but still 1992 yeah a long time you're
born yet
86 you're born 86 I was young I've got
boobs in 86
did you that's that's a good never
thought of that as a woman do you write
knows it go actually know to be fun I
know when I first got pubic hair 5050
yeah quite late with you British people
we're very reserved even even on has
reserved it waits like an extra three
years before that was quite good at all
right I have to say the bar is so low
out here cuz of Dick Van Dyke like it's
not that I'm relatively unoffending but
I had to do I'm I do a commercial
casting the other day and I was I did
the fur I got a callback and the first
one was in I said Canada in English in
the goin gonna tell your in normal
accent I was like yeah because I was
just talking him normally and I went
what you mean is this month do people
come in who Americans have pretend to be
English I went oh happens a lot happens
a lot and I was out really so then I
went to the callback and I did to admit
my thing and then there was you know
when it's the call when it's like seven
dudes sitting behind it's arena and hey
man can you were American I was like
yeah but with no run-up straight from
English went all over the shop it was
just I wanted to walk out since I was I
know I [ __ ] this up I said um hey dude
yeah when a bit went it went way too
like that because I've had a lesson
before and the person I just keep it
keep it as close to your own accent as
possible and don't let it be too much of
assets that thing is that that's why I
did that anything good but yeah when I
start thinking about it goes wrong I
said um you guys say Cecil instead of
sessile don't you the name well first of
all no one says Cecil with no one's
called Cecil know there was in this
script there was a Cecil but I reserved
I said soon you say one but then they
probably didn't people didn't know
anyway no no I'm sure some idiot came in
and called him cackle yeah yeah but what
I love about that I don't if you've ever
gangee I'd do anything to start with but
you go to these auditions and there's
and there's guys who come in the costume
so it was like in the wardrobe if they
come they've brought their own wardrobe
thinking like the budgets that tight
person's going to meet we can save a 50
bucks that guy's got his own Cyclops
outfit a guy came dressed guy came in
his own toga which was like a bedsheet
but you don't have to I feel like I
don't I feel like em when you're
investing in a you know don't go so far
as to wear a toga and then say cackle
yeah you're just [ __ ] up on but I'm
also thinking like not the only place he
was that they was in the audit like he
had to break into the audition sure in a
toga right at midday yeah and then get a
water on the way there at the 7-eleven
walked in in a tone I know so am know I
didn't get it but maybe maybe phone
wallet so ago we've got the part can I
tell you what you should be auditioning
for all these tell me um game shows no
the the recordings of businesses when
you first call businesses that want to
sound like they're way more important
than they are I always use a British
voice I really if you call the
world-famous Laugh Factory it's in a
British Bowie's oh yeah if you call like
different places so like for example I
think one of the high-end agencies they
use like a British chick when they
voiceover yeah so like you pick up and
you know it's not just someone that
answers like hello William Morris it's
like a it's it's a it's an outgoing
hello yes yes you've reached
William Morris talent agent your cool is
important right exactly so like we may
want to be like a fancy boutique
maybe should be knocking on the doors
it's just fancy shops in Melrose yeah
hi guys could use this voice anywhere
yes I'm telling you right now
I knew yeah that was the thing is it's
funny because everyone says about the
accent oh my god they love the accent
but it is it's but you know what it
worked for me the same way when I lived
in London really yeah so I was yours is
not in it yours is quite a nice America
it's not - no I'm very aggressive and
that voice sounds like I'm gargling
rocks bboy but I don't think so well
because you're British but um in the
states it's a I have a very aggressive
low Rumble II right Aaron don't you
think it's I mean it's one of your finer
qualities this is a rumble voice do you
have a sort of love/hate relationship
Aaron I know it's love love but my love
comes out like hate but it's love love
it's love love yeah for sure
you're like a my love is very aggressive
I guess aggressive love but when I was
in London I was a props mistress what is
that that sounds actually it's what you
think it is I put a candle stick up my
ass no I would go and try to get props
for these these theaters I'm wrong a
theatre look it's your word we don't use
that here in the States props miss
because mr. sounds like a fair you have
an affinity mistress well that's what
they call me the perhaps mr. props or
props is slight slang in the UK for like
proper like a proper mistress
oh no no props like we hey we need a
water bottle on sale yeah yeah no I get
it but it sound like something like I
could imagine a kid on this behave
myself we can kiss maybe four times if
you want yeah props mr. mystery and I
had to get a hundred or so bottles of
Verve click oh well and nobody could do
it Verve click oh did not want to give
us and just empty bottles not they
weren't full we just needed empty to
make it look and we would just fill it
with water or sight or whatever nobody
could get it done and I go you know what
I have a feeling if I call with my
accent and everyone's like no we've
already tried really and I did and they
were like where are you from because
they feel you like a movie star
yeah I think so and I called and I was
like hey I just need
just said 100 you know empty bottles
I'll come by I'll pick them up no
problem right away where are you from
the states
what part California well part of
California you know it was just like
they really yeah intrigued so I was like
oh yeah
they wanted to show off that that's
that's customer service that I'm not
used to in the UK maybe I've been maybe
need to dial up the America maybe you do
hey partners yeah it's over it's always
like yeah that was like surfer dudes I
did say I would add is he going does he
go in Venice he literally look like he
was out villains heads yeah that place
is great it's like it's early 90s Venice
is the point break could happen still
there right it is what we call a hot set
you know the hot setters no it's when
again so don't touch anything
don't touch anything this is a we're
shooting right now like it looks like
they're always shooting it looks like
there's no way this is real this is the
sound stage this is Warner Brothers
backlot with you it feels like
everyone's on display like it's not
really to one all right guys and action
most limit most of our life feels like
that any really I just like it was in
the supermarket yesterday I was there
there was a like a woman with her kid
she was dressed I was like this is I
won't sound like an old man no no mother
would dress like that and you gay I was
like this is this is very la it was just
like her dog was like Taos it's like
this isn't this is odd this is I can try
to get out the shop it just Lutz no you
guys don't have kids me and my wife do
not have kids yeah but British people in
general do have some british people do
yes yes I've seen yeah we don't have
kids
but two years married but you know we
potentially went how how early did you
have a child I was 16 16 I'm kidding no
you didn't say with my husband yeah no I
know I was not pregnant as it as a
teenager just to confirm that you tried
nobody would have sex with me oh I know
it's so good yeah because when I was
growing up it was like Christie Brinkley
do you know she is it was blondes it was
really blue eyes it was not this like
Hasidic immigrant face really no and now
guys all the rage now hey my wife's half
Filipino is she I can't get enough of
they can't for they the American what's
her other half Scottish that's kind of
fun what Scottish accent a Filipino face
is fun well her dad had dads it's
actually very sweet her dad is quite
that older than a mum but he they were
pen pals
he went to Philippines first me ever
left the UK met the airport fell in love
very sweet however if you saw them more
like at the time it still together still
together they're the most like in love
they're great in-laws but it's annoying
so I've got very high bar to reach in my
wife's eyes because he's like the
sweetest man ever never the most in love
couple oh my god if most people who saw
like him and her like the eight the age
difference is like 13 years maybe it's
not that bad but I still you know when
people in their head go older get older
white guy with Asian they always think
they always think something think he
adopted her and then married her yet
there's a there's an Fort that's enough
fortune that's the one thing is an old
white guy that isn't in your favor yeah
for about half a second people think
you're creepy than you are yeah
potentially but I wanna see a picture of
your wife yeah I'll show you yeah
and so that's on the back on the
background that's a very holy [ __ ] yes
she's smoking she's nice literally she
has a bong yeah she's on fire so what is
that like what was that can we interview
her what was that like for her to grow
up in Scotland that's what she said she
was the only they were the only
non-white people in her village so their
village she's well it's not village it's
like a town on the outskirts of
Edinburgh but they said there was never
like aggressive racism but it was more
like suppose it wasn't enough of them
for white people to be annoyed like oh
there's the happens I think they would
use like affectionate racial slurs about
Asians towards them like was something
more affectionate but what have you
heard it I say but it's kind of racist
but then Hannah just sort of normal I
always said to her like it's funny
because everything she did to those
white people was what they thought all
Filipinos are like so like a
three-legged cat so all their neighbors
I think for that's just Filipinos they
just have they just have Paralympic cats
that's like a thing in Asia so
everything they did was what they would
perceive as Filipino but it just and
does she speak to garlic good knowledge
of the Filipino
I grew up in school oh yeah yeah no so
she we went on our honeymoon there and
she did but she classic this is very my
wife she was like I'm gonna learn the
language I'm like great learn it and
then she learned for two weeks there was
like on it and then it's hard to learn
she's now got Spanish app on iPhone ten
minutes a day good she keeps going well
in Spanish might get a nap she's
actually on it can I tell you my first
day in London free day I go to find a
pay phone great it's a call home here is
this 19 so it's a long time ago already
1993 Oh post boobs post I did go to
London pre boobs you and I went post to
live 90 okay great yeah and I call I go
to call home say I landed you know and
there's an Asian guy in the phone in the
phone booth very small Asian no but he's
in the phone booth and I'm just standing
there and he pops his head out to say um
I'll just be a minute
like he's very polite but he has a very
thick British accent come in have an
agency so yeah like Liverpudlian oh
really it's funny when it's naughty I'm
just like what my first date I'm like
what is girls but even to British people
that is unusual yeah like um there's a
football as a team called a Newcastle
genu that was what made me laugh about
the backstage hear all things comedy
festival straight from Phoenix I went
backstage and there's a got a drinks cab
and they've got Bud Light they've got
some other beer and I got a Newcastle
Brown Ale is the third that's a weird
that's weird that's here that mean that
is [ __ ] they [ __ ] there we've had a
Newcastle Brown it's made originally of
the old [ __ ] that came out of like a
distilling process that they would chuck
in the drain it's the sausage of beers
it's beer sausage that's a good name for
its a bad name for the Newcastle Brown
it's [ __ ] disgusting I was 18 because
I mean drink some wine once in a while
I've had sips like oh here's a sip it
tastes like [ __ ] so I drink it I've
never like had a beer
really anyway justice or I just feel
like it's the ocean it tastes like the
ocean to me Oh bear that's a and my my
husband loves different types of beer
sue went out once this one place and
they had like some sort of chocolate
beer in the menu yes was like oh I gotta
try the chocolate beer he's like oh you
gotta taste this it's chocolate ocean
it's salty ocean water that's right he's
one of those drinks he like after a few
after several he likes a bit like I sort
of get the point of why bother putting
in that much ground were to enjoy a
drink orange juice is like strata the
gate but then again coffees not amazing
another coffee and I love it yeah so you
say you went through the hard work and I
caught you I can't be honest it makes me
[ __ ] as well which I don't want
oh you don't cuz usually humans like you
function is it I don't like some people
go I have a coffee Tim I go sort of I
don't need to know I don't find I don't
need a trigger mine so my best friend is
like yourself very extremely
aggressively Caucasian okay can I just
count on that for one second which I got
my hair cut yesterday by an else El
Salvadorian aha yes and he goes I don't
if you just say miss the moment it him
it worked
he said Italian menu I was like may I'm
the whitest guy I'm gonna tell my wife
said hey guys I was Italian they go why
do you got me tell you is are you bid as
I may I'll take every day the way it's
the closest to non-white have ever got
but yeah I am shockingly cocaine Marion
he was wrong and her husband is Filipino
yep and their children are the most
beautiful beings I have ever seen in my
life now I'm not just saying it because
my best friend yeah they are stunningly
beautiful yeah I'm looking for was
having huge yeah be good and and they
went to the Philippines also really
don't know if it was honeymoon but it
was definitely like you know well I'm
marrying a Filipino dude so I guess I'm
gonna go you do it and she said it was
the craziest trip of her really yeah
it's like have you been I've never been
it is amazing
it's uh they're the nicest people ever
yeah like as in sometimes you guys in
country sounds like a broad stereotype
but you can be good but then people
trying to sell you stuff with their so
the most respectful people you've never
met in my life and it's yeah it so I
would go if I had enough money I'd go
every year without fail yeah
quality although they have got the most
disgusting food also much you know their
national dish I was at that eggwin it's
called balute yes it just smells like
ass right it's [ __ ] I mean I didn't I
wouldn't know it I mean again like you
with a beer might I can tell I'm not I'm
not gonna have to I want a grimace
through 10 minutes - I just don't get it
like there's other things yeah red
licorice yeah like how bad is your like
Lada that you're going we're gonna have
to have egg fetuses again but like alive
alive like just alive alive enough we're
like you can see them smiling yeah any
time an egg has a face in it is it's bad
egg enough for me yeah anytime an
animal's face is still intact and you're
about to eat it like when they leave the
head on a fish how do you feel about
that the idea people where the eyes the
best bit there's always some one kid
that doesn't you know what was something
this is the shittiest thing there's
always some like contrary and person
ever banana it's Bruce Bruce bits but no
it's not the best it's not it's the
worst bit and you just have to be
different and the eye there's nowhere
the eye is the best bar my god come on I
don't think you can bite through it well
I don't I am Carl my normal partner in
crime he's full vegan no leather shoes
and I am trying to be and by that I mean
I occasionally like occasionally slip
off of it I mean I wear leather shoes or
whatever but
oh he's for these faux leather he's full
washes his armpits with stuff that
doesn't wash your armpits
the nice thing Carl you know that's true
you know I tried I I weave in and out of
that world yeah yeah I'm similar I wanna
I wanna be I wanna be in it but it's
hard it's so hard but the problem is
Carl doesn't make me feel I want to go
I'm basically vegan he goes you can't
you can't say that if you're not so
great I guess say you eat a heavily
plant-based diet I think that sounds
even one care to say that right so I
kinda do I try to not really say but
people always want to know it was comes
up I try to sneak fake food what I call
I call it fake food because it's trying
to be yeah yeah chicken with a queue
yeah it's like eh IQ which also sounds
like a woman at the DMV
get the rights to the real thing right
yeah and I sneak it in and I buy it for
my kids and they'll eat it you know and
sometimes my husband I'll try to trick
him into some V doesn't work sometimes
if it's a great restaurant because there
are a couple vegan restaurants that he
loves all right he's not tricked he
knows how I'm observant as your husband
isn't even work out the menus blindfold
him back of a van but it's hard it's
hard to do like right now we're on the
road right I mean I guess okay there's
some veggies here yeah okay that was
that was more vegetables than you would
normally get in yeah some pets of the
Eukarya was showing them like I went
into a supermarket like something like I
was a witch hello my crisps or a
sandwich like a normal person yes potato
chips crisps is a good word though right
yeah you wish you had that word and it's
not crispy I love it and I love [ __ ]
[ __ ] is a good one as well about
merit if our American listeners are
listening they are at the name of a type
of meat and Tom state a Canadian commune
has a very funny like ten minute routine
about being in a market in like the
Midlands in the UK and a guy selling
[ __ ] and the back of a van yeah like
it's a real thing it just tells the
whole story like as it happen it's just
like yeah that's a real thing I mean I
bought frozen [ __ ] really that's I
bet you just enjoy the [ __ ] exact word
obviously you can't say oh but I'm
saying it you can say and it's fine it's
legit is that okay it's fine saying it
in the British sense
hey saying in the British sense like a
cigarettes called a [ __ ] that's right
that well he went to the UK you could
just say [ __ ] and [ __ ] for like a
couple it's I wish I got so hazed when I
lived there how long were you there for
a year yeah ah would you ever get would
you ever live there London's cool
London's amazing and you know where I
live this is a long time ago
Notting Hill game a lovely bit of town
right next to Portobello market of the
other side of that which was less nice
but great markets awesome my dad is
Caucasian I am my dad sells old books on
Portobello market oh my god are you out
of a Harry Potter [ __ ] are you
yes every Saturday he sells a old old
books antiquarian books and ephemera
which it means old bits of paper come on
real real talk paper yeah but ephemera
it's called is the name ephemera
ephemeral items that's amazing and
quaint and just so cute and I can see
him eating a biscuit and having a tea he
is a big guy he's a lot of it biscuits
is good cuz you guys have that weird
weird biscuit it's like a big scone your
best skills scone we don't have this get
chicken and biscuits that's a wig but
it's not a proper business but that's
but it's called a biscuit oh okay yeah
we have those biscuit it's not real
biscuit no no you have cookies right
what's your biscuits yeah they're not as
good as you making me actually miss home
I mean diamond eat half these things
where things make me like miss the UK
having back if like a month like I've
got a jar of Marmite in my cupboard do
you have that no no do you know what it
is I do if you don't drink baby it's
Satan's semen that's what that is you
are eating Satan's semen you love it or
you hate it
yeah that's one I like by totally go I
can totally see on paper it's the shitty
sounding thing I get is disguise I get
its salt it's just salt that is almost I
think Newcastle Brown Ale is made of the
same bread form that's like British soy
sauce it's no humane what's about that I
got hazed yeah because they would take a
cigarette and a tea break every I'm not
kidding you 15 minutes because I worked
in a theatre but that was a union
theatre yeah so they had to yeah and
they would have you know in the break
room magazines but they were all like
playboys great all of them great and
they had them there like it was like a
you know home and garden love like it
was cash it doesn't I didn't s everyone
I don't know it's not like doctor's
waiting rooms there that flame
I understand thought that is funny these
guys and they were such dicks with a
proper geezer is not palpable oh god
yeah and talked about they are all from
Liverpool they fall
and I even did it if anyone wants to go
listen to our ATC podcast yeah
no no the crab feeds not even mine I did
a story on the crab piece about how they
try to murder me on yeah Hitler and
Larsen's crab feast may try to another
time we'll get you on here to tell that
story I will link to it and they tried
to kill me in London in a theatre
this is one of the best and the worst
cliffhangers in the podcast and we just
the height I mean obviously you didn't
die so we kind of know the end how do
you know
yeah maybe the ghosts aren't anything
where they just had a killer or avril
lavigne that's the other one she's
apparently dead oh she is because her
handwriting is different like me also
like who like who gives a [ __ ] you know
who gives a [ __ ] she's dead but means
there's that Paul McCartney want to get
the Paul McCartney when is a winger but
every what you think I know what I just
think there's too many so how to have a
fake person come on as long as too many
people after I said gullible I am like
well maybe that's why I'm believing it
but like how many people have to not
tell someone the truth over that long a
period I would tell someone like within
two weeks no way I'm keeping that to
myself I can't wait to go that's why
they didn't tell you because I know
you're a bloody bastard thanks for
coming cure Christopher Christopher John
Marcin feelings my full name oh my god
you're so light very um we'll do it
again yeah let's do again go have a fun
show see you later
thank you we'll keep I'll keep talking
to Erin that's how are you man I am good
lovely thanks Kira take your crew take
your crudité with you do you call that
hit that here as well
crudité do you know the words soiree
yeah as soon as she's off mic the
relationship goes to [ __ ] doesn't it
yeah yeah it was all a big fake thing on
the microphone seer caretaker
he's something I want to speak to you
about Erin sure you've got a good name
Erin right it's a proper American name
Elvis's middle name is it just LA or is
it America where there's a trend to give
your kid this most ridiculous name
as in his his it spread from LA to the
rest of the country I think did I tell
this on the last podcast about when I
met a kid called towns no I met a
child's called I like it in the park and
this little kid who's like four and
Hannah and now what's was what's your
name
he went towns and I went towns and his
mum went town like like town like town
with an S on the end but like she was
shitty with me but she said it like she
said it like no I heard the word but the
reason I was surprised is because that
isn't that isn't the name no you can't
just do that you can't just be like it's
it's dogs a dog with an S on the end
it's still it's [ __ ] Laurel of a word
it's a brotherhood it's still not a name
yeah towns come on man you can't call
your kids is just dog want to come back
in you want to come back in no no he
doesn't want it now it's just like
creepily staring fairies of toying with
you now it's just way through the window
like that leave him okay so that's just
a new that's the Knicks in the UK knows
a face like people calling their kids
like like champagne and yeah it feels
like it's died out there's a lot of
there's a shocking number of Jaden's out
there Jaden are you Jaden's okay no
you're too old to be Jade are you guys
just them fans that walks in off the
street quality this is great I'm from
the UK my name is Chris you can tell
there we go yeah you go yeah that's not
I'm not putting it on I love that we've
got people this is great the studio
people just walking in and just change
it so towns not have you guys got can I
just check what you have you got proper
American names what's your name
Kumar Oh doesn't Sam that's a good name
they keep and we got Anna and I hang on
this is just yet we've got Doug Stanhope
muniya ng through the window can I take
a photo this this is [ __ ] hilarious
amazing did you guys think you're gonna
see Doug Stanhope [ __ ] today what's
good and you can tell it's his [ __ ]
cuz he's wearing the jacket he always
works yeah he's got the worst moon iing
ass ever yeah yeah is that a thing in
America you stay at the school bus
window as well when you go into like
sports games and stuff is that a British
thing
now over school bus we used to put our
bums on the windows which sounded really
British when I said that bums on the
windows when you go with that light down
the street where would you do it out of
like a friend's car
I like that difference in America okay
like we did but we didn't do it on
school time yeah yeah we did it after
our education serious we took education
seriously and we had a set for an
[ __ ] into the atmosphere time that's
amazing and here's one thing I want to
speak about before it and this is a it's
Halloween weekend right so this is go
this is a crazy weekend of here it's so
fun it's my first time in America for
Halloween so do you know in the UK we
don't give a [ __ ] about Halloween that
is in it's it's nothing like we get
actively angry that there are children
trying to get free sweeties off us so
like if it's Halloween like you guys
love it you guys dress up you have this
whole thing where there's part that the
lyft driver I got the lady Jessica she
invited me to a Halloween party this
weekend $65 for a ticket
ooh that's not normal thought that $65
for a in Phoenix in flex money in
Phoenix that's a lot right and I was
like hey man yeah Kira's just gone she's
gone to get the thing yeah and yeah $65
for Hannah I was like oh what a clue
drinks ninety-five includes two drinks
whoa what's happening at these Halloween
parties yes if there's no like haunted
house element to it there's not an
actual ghost it's not a real nobody died
if something doesn't die and you do a
seance after that's a [ __ ] ripoff but
like in the UK we on the night we no one
has anything else at the house you turn
all your lights off and pretend you're
not in so that you don't have to give a
kiss yeah we do that here oh you do but
when I was driving right now that maybe
people have got ridiculous decorations
if you've got kids you know yeah yeah
yeah and you if you decorate you're
gonna you're gonna have candy and stuff
yeah no that'd be the worst thing that's
amazing decorations they turn off and
you just got lice and cucumbers and [ __ ]
yeah there was always it when I did it
as a kid like we started came in like I
didn't you holiday in the UK you'd go
around and it'd be funny when you just
like knock on someone's door and they
didn't know it's Halloween but they were
kind of nice so they thought they're
just trying to improvise so and
sometimes people just put like pennies
in the bag you coming in
come on Doug
please join me I was flying solo you
guys can all join
hey man I'm Chris hey who is it Tracy as
you were saying yeah we're so tired of
this comedy festival being about comedy
and we want to talk about social issues
that mean a lot to a lot of people yeah
like okay hahaha yeah Harvey Weinstein
blah blah blah but what about Amazon
hanging tanks no not return policy you
cannot return and Tracy you were saying
you had a very whatever you were saying
but Tracy Tracy is the good [ __ ]
what's wrong insight on so many social
issues look at the big picture people
like but they don't look at the big pig
no all things comedy how about all
things [ __ ] serious yeah I mean I
didn't Street how many female comedians
as you see yeah okay anyway the point is
a matter throw one or two in like it's a
hard enough female opinions about things
Tracy who is completely underrated
there's a human being right I mean tell
them what you were telling us what was
this one here I can say it better she's
not representative nah not even enough
no and it takes men like us to try to
put out a female voice to hell with you
which is a pull yourself up by your girl
where they can noam chomsky of a I'll
get it later
don't talk point being this is the
nobody listens to this podcast podcast
and it's actually good but it's the
voice of women yeah and I got I got I
got bullet points yeah it's this is the
voice of women podcast we're talking to
you live and I got a call okay can you
take a call for me hmm hey is there
coffee could you grab us some coffee
take the call and get us coffee this is
the voice of women podcast we are the
voice of women we would help and help
yourself is that kill Steen on the phone
hang on hang on this is a perfect
accident Jamie Jamie kill Steen you're
on the voice of women behind guys don't
screw up this side hey yes can you just
try to enunciate what Tracy's been
trying to say because she has a great
point of view but we can do it better
you're both over talking each other I'll
see ya Oh
I'll see you home I always say it better
than he would all right yeah okay
he's coming in there is oh there he is
man oh you're here come okay hey hey man
what Tracy was trying to say because she
has a brilliant point of view as a woman
yeah and she was trying Tracy could you
send the other seat Matt yeah hey Tracy
no Tracy come back over here and sit on
my lashes there that early style yeah
come sit on my lap no because you should
be above us because you were saying this
she had this brilliant point about the
dichotomy between rich and poor Kay what
about equal pay say what you're saying
about
we were talking about equal pay you
don't know but the thing is if you got
equal pay that we couldn't afford to buy
your drinks so yeah I'd be we yeah no
well no I'm talking about me you and
Jamie kill Steen and this guy I don't
know he crashed our podcast we're not
getting paid the same we're four guys it
we should begin to equal pay we're both
equally funny at this moment and Tracy a
grab with some coffee
yeah can you spot me Tracy I don't have
enough cash hey hey
Tracy uh we're gonna go do sushi yeah
we're gonna follow this up get us a
table by Jersey white rice where's your
girl
house she's right there oh nice good hey
you know what she also has interesting
points of view and we'll get to those
after we have sushi let's tell them what
they have to say
all right thanks for listening my ball
the boys with women
voice of I'm chair Jamie thanks guys
thanks guys Erin yes finally yeah I like
that as a guy he's so excited so excited
he was walking along the street he saw
Stanhope talking about women he had to
come in I like these two you guys stay
through the bitter end
you know I don't care who they pop what
the podcast is yeah you have followers
I've got followers this guy's come in
thank you guys come in Bob's but look at
this this is American dudes coming in
hey guys from the UK I've come to
Phoenix of the first time what should I
do in Phoenix I've got one day tomorrow
to kill stay in the aircon all right
there we go
that's just are you gonna be here for
all upset I love tomorrow all of
tomorrow you were in LA
you could go to the the Santa Monica
Halloween parade I could go to that all
right but like your thing in LA you have
to go to Asti
it's insanity and there's a solo
elaborate really it's a huge block party
in Boystown
that's like Boys Town we call that Soho
in London yeah
boys tell me something different I take
it it doesn't mean where you go to find
boys well it's the game part of oh it's
actually called I thought that was a
joke it's actually called Boys Town why
it's the nickname okay it's not on the
map as boys
you don't put boys down into google map
all right I should go to that okay but
I'm annoyed because where I'm staying in
LA they're closing my Road on Sunday for
a Halloween yeah does that mean I can
drive my car down the road what's the
vibe on that if I live there can you
move your car on a closed-off Street
yeah I think well this is just okay
local traffic is okay you'll find this
is this is admin that I need to get
sorted but I haven't got I also can't be
else with a car you've got to make you
buy a proper costume and all this [ __ ] I
mean you don't have to are you gonna do
something Tuesday night have you got an
outfit sorted and I'm like recycling we
even brought one here
what do you what have you brought is
your Superman I have the scorpion jacket
from Drive that's not a Halloween outfit
that's just a male fantasy that that's
something you I want to wear every week
who doesn't want to be like Ryan Gosling
every weekend not just for Halloween how
much does that cost you by the way I
think I look that up straight after the
film drive I watch it and sit him on
mate and I drove back really fast
afterwards yeah I was like we watched
him like let's just drive back quick
like through a residential area and then
I looked up that there's like quiet it
was a lot at the time and I waited a
couple years and so it was like 40 bucks
that's all right that's that that's a
good I love that you inspired but also
on a budget no I literally was going to
do it the year after it came out and I
forgot until it was too late so no okay
I had to wait a year I'm Carl my co-host
in the UK he um he bought a maroon suit
off the back of Ryan Gosling rona and
the film Crazy Stupid Love
you have to be Gosling to pull off a
maroon suit yeah scorpion jacket maroon
suit glove fingerless gloves not driving
gloves yes driving you have those you
have driving dogs for the outfit yeah
but
do you like to wear them do you wear
driving gloves in a car when I Drive
through canyons I only like divorced
dads where driving gloves in the UK
that's amazing
full driving gloves that's great and
we've got guys you guys from Phoenix
over here quality right you guys podcast
listeners love this stuff
do you guys listen to this one no it's
from the UK I'm the one UK
representative at this all things comedy
festival but we are if you I don't know
what you guys know about the UK fans of
British stuff no not really
I feel like Americans anything they know
about the UK what's that British movies
which what's your favourite British
movie Shaun of the Dead is classed that
is good I feel like the only TV guys
really get is Harry Potter like a Harry
Potter film I don't mind a Harry Potter
film and what's that Downton Abbey on TV
you know you guys don't I feel like you
need to educate yourself
Sherlock's alright you know what I like
Sherlock for the first season or so now
it's just too much like his mind palace
I'm like [ __ ] off mate let's downsize
that let's get a mind studio apartment
and there's episode half an hour shorter
it's too much but I was talking about we
were talking American names and we got
that man's eye have you guys got normal
American names we've got an hour and
what we've got over here
Darren love that as proper American huh
Jason was that tanner
basket Tanner let's go that's cool
Tanner I've never heard that before
no it's is it is it a common American
name cuz like what do you guys think of
a common English name Philip do you know
you don't get Philips over here Ian
Ian's quite English name yeah Gary's you
get Gary's over here oh yeah you know
the you know Gary's are dying out as a
genuine is a name like last year there
were no people named Gary when they were
like babies but if you look at the baby
and call it Gary you're a sociopath
right yeah no one's ever looked at a
child and thought Gary Aaron I'll give
you these these are cool names they work
for children and adults but like Gary's
gone I think like
Kevin that's a weird kid's name no
wonder in that movie that got keV keV
for a baby baby no wonder that kids in
that movie shot everyone up
that who's like kevin is not a suitable
name for me that was quite sorry I was a
quite edgy thing to mention on the
podcast but anyway fine UK we don't have
guns so I'm just I do want it someone
said in Phoenix actually I should go to
a gun range how much would it cost me to
get can i I will go to a gun range
tomorrow if any wants to take me how
much does it costs to go to a gun range
just rent a gun 20 30 bucks and I just
go in there and they just let me shoot
like a round of bullets yeah what I'm
worried about is I'm gonna [ __ ] love
it that's what I'm worried about
Jonah mean like I'm gonna do it and I'm
gonna be go back to the UK and be like
guys what working up on a gun from
nowhere here's a truncheon knock
yourself out literally knock yourself
out so you can do the truncheon and I've
got even working you buy a gun here
everywhere you go can you actually go
into Walmart and buy one yeah
that is insane what do I need his ID
passport a state resident okay that's
fine though no - okay once again Trump
stopping the tourists getting what they
want you've gotta have it I could go to
Walmart how much does a gun cost roughly
150 dollar gun yeah I was looking at
vacuum cleaner today there were 150
that's that's where my life's at at the
moment I'm looking how to keep dust at
my house for and how to kill people
got 150 bucks I've gotta have it I will
have a go $30 never go tomorrow right
what we talking like just like handgun
what's a good starter gun for someone
who's never shot one before
nine-millimeter is that one that like
him the cops haven't lethal weapon yeah
not the danny glover one the smith and
western wear which I don't understand
now and it who would get one of them in
this day and age is so much get six
bullets yeah takes a long time to reload
it's good for Russian Roulette it's
about the only thing it's good for yeah
in 9 min amis not great for that you
know your basic gonna shoot yourself in
the head each time you click it yeah
mate I've got a we're gonna probably
wrap this up yeah that was an
interesting podcast yeah we have a few
at all so Doug stan has our soul
followed by him talking [ __ ] for 10
minutes ironically which is fun it was
good fun hey guys thanks for coming oh
you got you got umm what's the next one
on next one is punch-drunk
punch-drunk sports dudes are here you
guys are here for the sport you guys you
guys look like sports fans should I get
his air a sport I should be checking out
well in America I want to only get into
a game
baseball's of World Series basketball I
like it but I did live ask him I did go
to this is true I went to one hockey
game in Anaheim in the only thing I
remember I don't member score a number
two things I remember the ice got
cleaned by really sexy ladies which made
me laugh I was like how would that all
the most qualified people for cleaning
the ice happen to be really attractive
women and the second thing that happened
was I went to the toilet a half time and
I saw a man walk into a stall eating a
pizza and I thought welcome to America
Chris this is everything is possible in
this country guys thanks a lot for
listening and listeners thanks for for
listening in it's a weird one about car
but it was a fun little fun that one
Erin jump we had many people joining and
it's great fun and if you've enjoyed the
podcast you can check it out check out
other ones on Carl and Chris podcast
comm keep up to date on a Facebook group
Facebook become for such : Chris and we
got babysitting Trevor season 2 spin-off
podcast coming out on Thursday the 2nd
of November check it out and keep
listening car will do different on next
week I'll see you guys soon take a
cheese plate am I supposed to do the top
of the pod